philippe emmanueli bonjour vous êtes
médecin vous exercer à barcelone alors
comment vit-on cette levée progressive
des mesures de restriction alors que le
pays était strictement confiné depuis un
mois et demi eh bien écoutez cette levée
du confinement est vécue comme une
véritable bouffée d'oxygène par la
population qui est descendue en masse
dans la rue aux heurts qui ont été
réouverts notamment pour se promener et
pour faire du sport il faut dire que les
espagnols ne sont pas habitués à vivre à
l'intérieur de leur maison et que la vie
s'exprime la plupart du temps à
l'extérieur et donc on sent depuis
depuis la réouverture de ces horaires la
joie est lent vie de la population de
retrouver le chemin des espaces publics
en tant que médecin comment jugez-vous
la gestion des autorités espagnoles de
cette crise sanitaire côté c'est
difficile de porter un jugement
ce qu'on peut dire c'est que l'espagne
aujourd'hui joue la carte du
desserrement progressif du confinement a
annoncé un calendrier avec
éventuellement la possibilité de revenir
en arrière si les contaminations
vais repartir à la hausse est donc
aujourd'hui tout le monde rognard des
chiffres en surveillant l'apparition
d'un robot cette crainte d'une deuxième
vague donc poussé un petit peu les
autorités à mettre en place le port du
masque obligatoire dans les transports
en commun dès demain c'est une nouvelle
qui a été accueillie comment par la
population à espagnol écouter la
population en est réduit à suivre les
consignes qui lui sont donnés chaque
jour face à l'épidémie
on voit apparaître finalement peu de
critiques de fond sur sur la gestion de
la crise
il faut dire que tout le monde est bien
conscient ici des inconnus qui reste
quant au futur de cette épidémie est
donc chaque nouvelle qui va dans le sens
d'une protection active contre
l'épidémie et d'un retour à la vie
normale est accueillie ici avec une
forme d'optimisme et de soulagement
concernant la reprise du travail est ce
que le gouvernement a donné quelques
pistes sur les sur la date possible
alors oui le gouvernement a annoncé
maintenant un calendrier de reprise du
travail et notamment de réouverture des
petits commerces
ici comme ailleurs en europe les gens
maintenant attendre de retourner chez le
coiffeur
c'est chose faite à partir de lundi
prochain puisqu'il sera possible d'aller
chez son coiffeur sur rendez vous c'est
chose faite aussi pour les entreprises
de restauration et les bars pour
lesquelles on a annoncé une date de
réouverture à condition de limiter les
capacités d'accueil à 50% et que ses
capacités d'accueil soient développées
sur les terrasses dernière question
concernant les tests on sait que la
france va entamer justement là
ce chemin d'essayer de tester le plus
possible la population pour éviter
justement une propagation du virus est
ce que l'espagne va faire la même chose
est ce que vous avez à plus
d'informations concernant les tests
alors pour le moment l'espagne a annoncé
une période de sondage
c'est à dire qu'un certain nombre de
tests pour être fait de façon aléatoire
dans la population pour déterminer quel
est le niveau de circulation du virus
pour le moment c'est la seule chose qui
a été annoncé et on n'est pas encore
rentré dans une stratégie de tests
systématiques
notamment parce que il faut bien le dire
les tests restent difficiles d'accès en
espagne merci beaucoup philippe
emmanueli d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes médecin à barcelone